[Music]
see your survey we did it thanks so much
for being a great partner on the
strategic communications project your
progress on your learning goals was
admirable and you are incredibly helpful
online best player it is so easy to hand
write a letter it takes just a minute
but we don't do it very often think
about the last time that you went to
your mailbox and open a real letter you
probably felt amazing the art of
handwriting doesn't have to be dead
today we're going to talk to you about
the power of handwritten communication
when you can employ handwriting over
digital communications and share with
you some examples from our own life
about when it's been moving for us this
really we know that plan written
communications are better but why is
this first they're more memorable in a
deluge of snaps and blasts and emails a
handwritten letter really stands out
they're also longer-lasting now you may
argue that email is eternal and in the
literal sense you'd probably be right
but we don't print out our text messages
and put them on our refrigerator or save
them in a box that we go you know review
on a rainy day and in that sense and
writing last longer they also
demonstrate a much deeper personal
investment in the relationship knowing
that somebody took time out of their day
to sit down jot down a little note get a
postage stamp and put it in the mail
it's incredibly powerful for the
recipient lastly handwritten
communication will improve your health
reduce anxiety help you sleep better a
little bit of an exaggeration but it's
been proven that people who take time
out of their day to write down their
gratitude have a deeper satisfaction
with life so now we know a few reasons
why hand written communication is more
power
pull I'm going to pass it off declare to
talk about when we can use the tool tell
me there are many different types of
handwritten communication you can send
thank-you cards the Suzanne sorry
send condolences or congratulations or
holiday cards so next time you think
about sending a text or an email why not
send a handwritten note instead Ben and
I are now going to walk through a few
examples from our lives of when
handwritten communication has impacted
our relationship in preparing for this
presentation we all went through our
papers and figured out what we held on
to over the years I found this note from
almost ten years ago for my college
roommate it was really just written just
because she wanted to say that she was
sorry for being a bad roommate recently
which is sure we can all relate to and
also to wish me luck on my consulting
interviews but I really really stuck
with me and I held on to it for all
these years it's pretty interesting this
demonstrates the permanence of
handwritten communication and she just
sent me a text or said she was sorry in
person I certainly wouldn't have held on
to it for this long but it also wouldn't
have impacted our relationship in the
same way now going to pass it on to Ben
for another example Thank You clear so a
few weeks ago my girlfriend and I
celebrated our one-year anniversary yep
and to celebrate this amazing milestone
we of course went out to a 5-horse fancy
surf and turf but what I will remember
is not the food that we ate in fact it
won't even be the meal itself what our
remember for the years to come is this
lovely handwritten piece of work art
that my girlfriend Lou has given to me
should I read a few lives here yes
okay alright if you must
it has been a year and what a year it
has been
thanks for the chairs and chuckles
cuddles and hustle and all the bear hugs
and monkey bits okay I'll stop right
here before she finds out is mr. paws
and throws me in my sleep but through
her piece of handwritten love note to me
I feel loved and cherished the
handwritten note captured lose care
kindness and topics I know I know what
you guys are thinking not everyone is as
smooth and pull it up like Lou did but
don't worry sir B is here to show you a
few shortcuts any time middle notes to
people we care about would be really
amazing but how do we find time to write
all these notes how do we think of the
content there article one one thought
funny words then all you actually need
to person is the letter
not every notes need to be as details or
long as what's been received from loop
that's for like special occasions but
for most occasions something which a
person thought specific to the audience
would be enough to make it memorable let
me share an example I am sure every
during every holiday season we all
receive a lot of cards or maybe just
emails nowadays last time when I was
going through the stack of all my cards
the one which stood out to me was for my
cousin it was a simple printed note but
on that he had added a note for me same
dear Sophie hope you are enjoying being
back at school they think of you every
time we are discussing school for Arlen
that's all that's all that is so but is
there a way we can use this power in
business settings that's where we all
are headed to be able to use communicate
effectively in business places yes we
can and in the same way let's take a
step back and think why do we actually
communicate yourselves goal in online
business settings
it's to persuade we want to persuade our
audience to act and do as per our
recommendation
Roberts Theogony the famous psychologist
in his book influence mentioned handed a
note to be a really strong tool of
persuasion he talks about yoga rod
Joe was a legendary salesman who sold an
average of 35 carbs every week for 15
years of his career 35 cars is a really
big number and how did he do that he
created an emotional connection with his
audience with a spline every month Joe
would sit down print out a few cards and
write a note to each of the splines
it was one specific part to them his
clients we're special they like love Joe
every time they had to buy a new car
also just I recommend a person to curb
their friends it was Joe I need Mr
conjoining but I am NOT going to be
selling cars so how do I apply this well
let's have a look at it I'm sure all of
you hear of listening similar letter in
last two years at least the Pearson GSB
and what is the first thing you that
grabs your attention here it's a
handwritten note by direct in the bottom
and let's stand out this letter arrived
for all of us in a very interesting
moment it's the moment when all of us
are valid are paying different options
hvh versus GFC MBA or not an MVA this
creates an instant emotional connection
this leads to a subtle persuasion and it
comes within 24 to 48 hours of that call
from during the previous day it does
have an impact I felt really special
that he mentioned not just me but also
my husband in this pen is really special
Ted direct Road congratulations in
Chinese books and it's same case with
all of my other friends we all are
confident in these notes are very
specific to us but it happens this is
surely more than when it works and how
do you write 500 of these a video there
is a template to this if you look at
these notes they're for par so it
five to ten words specific to each
person in that note but those words are
really specific to you so that's all
that effort it takes and we all are here
at CSP CSP has the highest acceptance
rate among among applicants how can we
apply this going ahead in our business
setting next time when you are welcoming
someone new to your team oh you are
handing out the promotion letter to your
promotion or a pay raise letter to your
team member take a minute take a minute
to write a thought personal to them on
that printed formal letter they will not
remember this printed form a little but
that personal note will take you a
really long way it will stick with them
thank you survey now we hope you're as
excited as we are to employ written
communication to your heart's content
but before you do that ask yourself this
question we will hand written
communication be more effective or
impactful in the situation five years
ago I received a piece of Henry's and
work with beautiful handwriting but I
must say it was the worst resume I've
ever seen in my life it is crushed my
soul when I noticed that she still had
nine more to go when as she walked
around to other companies at the career
fair when simply does not use a
handwritten resume when applying to a
software engineering position just like
we can handwrite our PowerPoint
presentation today though I don't want
any Henrich and resume from you I do
appreciate it if you send me any Henrich
and thank-you notes after I'll talk or
I'll joke set aside we hope you walk out
of this with the following key takeaways
one why do we write handwritten notes it
can be memorable it can be very
thoughtful and it builds stronger and
lasting relationships and some even say
it improves the quality of life - you're
in communication notes can be used in
many locations such as love notes and
mating
and lastly you don't have to handwrite
an entire essay sometimes you can add a
personal touch and use the general
templates to make them more thoughtful
and impactful and it can be applied to
both personal and professional settings
so we're now open up for Q&A and we
encourage you to take handwritten notes
able to help you remember more and
perhaps does I have your life
[Music]